alors tout à l'heure dans la dernière
partie du parcours entre kensington et
l'abbaye de westminster les sentes
associations caritatives auxquelles
diana participé d'une façon ou d'une
autre
seront représentés dans le cortège de
ces derniers temps diana s'étaient
beaucoup investis dans la lutte contre
l'exclusion ici là et puis ensuite pour
la suppression des mines antipersonnel
le destin a voulu que mère teresa
disparaissent également hier celle qui
avait choisi de consacrer sa vie aux
plus pauvres d'entre les plus pauvres
s'est éteinte à quelques temps il avait
87 ans les deux femmes se connaissaient
s'apprécier les mère teresa avait
justement fait savoir qu'elles ne
pourraient pas assister aux obsèques de
lady diana
geneviève moll lady diana dmir est
profondément mère teresa qu'elle
considérait comme un exemple vivant de
charité quelque part son action la
guider la princesse de galles comme
chaque princesse de la famille royale
visitez les jeunes accouchées bien sûr
mais diana ne se déplaçait jamais sans
demander à rencontrer des enfants
souffrent comme ici à lille dans un
service de maladies génétiques
métaboliques de l'enfant en visite à
paris pour une soirée de charité de la
fondation pour l'enfance d'anne aymone
giscard d'estaing elle se rend dans une
crèche de quartiers défavorisés de la
capitale
cette compassion elle va la mettre en
oeuvre pour lutter contre le cancer et
plus fortement encore contre le sida
là elle prendra même des positions très
appuyé incidemment rampe à ceux qui en
sont atteints dangereux vous pouvez
parfaitement leur serrer la main ou leur
donner l'accolade besoin pour aider les
plus démunis pour venir au secours de
ceux qui n'ont rien elles vont même une
partie de sa garde-robe chez christie's
à new york
les produits de la vente vont à des
oeuvres caritatives
au début de cette année elle découvre
les ravages causés sur les civils par
les mines antipersonnel au cambodge en
particulier et la lutte contre ces
engins de mort qui mutile 2000 personnes
par an devient son principal combat
début juillet elle se rend en bosnie où
chaque jour ses mines font toujours des
victimes
elle écoute à sarajevo le récit de deux
jeunes garçons l'un serbe l'autre
musulman qui ont perdu une jambe à cause
de ces mines sont combats acharnés
avaient immédiatement rallier l'adhésion
du premier ministre tony blair à l'idée
d'une interdiction totale de ces engins
à oslo les participants à la conférence
contre les mines antipersonnel ont
observé lundi une minute de silence en
hommage à la princesse de galles le
monde entier représentés dans cette
salle rendait hommage à celle qui avait
choisi d'utiliser son image et sa voix
produire le malheur des autres